bonsoir que de blanchemaison merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
pourquoi la russie at elle choisi comme
interlocuteurs européens
la finlande d'abord parce que la
finlande et sa voisine et qu'elle
partage avec elle 1350 km de frontière
que helsinki a une longue tradition de
dialogue avec avec moscou et donc les
deux ministres ont évidemment évoqué le
dans le détail leurs relations
bilatérales qui d'ailleurs vents vont
assez bien les commissions mixtes
réunissent les ministres se voit les
échanges commerciaux fonctionnent les
responsables échangent leurs points de
vue et par conséquent les relations
bilatérales sont bonnes ça c'était le
premier aspect mais deuxième aspect
c'est que le choix de d'helsinki était
était en fait la poursuite de la visite
de joseph bourrel à oskou sa
continuation en quelque sorte avec la
démonstration que monsieur lavrov a
voulu apporter les relations
institutionnelles entre la russie et
l'union européenne en tant que telle ne
fonctionnait plus puisque depuis sept
ans il n'y avait pas eu de semaine
puisque les aubes sectoriels seraient
laissés plus en revanche les relations
avec les états membres
continuer de fonctionner et la substance
des relations est en fait porté par les
entreprises par les agents économie
fonctionner normalement
et donc il a fini par dire que en effet
ou bien l'union européenne voulait veut
rétablir de bonnes relations sont à son
échelon l'union européenne en tant que
telle ou bien il n'y avait plus
d'intérêt pour la russie a considéré
qu'elle avait des relations avec l'union
européenne en tant que telle ceci pour
l'union européenne en tant que telle
naturellement ne concerne absolument pas
d etat mans donc il a apporté sa
démonstration qui d'ailleurs est
explicitée dans une interview très
détaillé qui la donnaient à un organe
russe
le 12 février dernier et dont il a été
question pendant la conférence de presse
assez longuement la finlande
claude blanche maison qui est aussi
membre d'une coopération nordique la
russie s'adresse donc à d'autres pays à
travers elle oui alors cette coopération
nordique comporte la suède le danemark
la finlande mais aussi l'islande et tous
ces pays discutent entre eux de leurs
intérêts économiques communs
ce club n'est pas un club exclusif
puisque les états membres de ceux de ce
groupement peuvent aussi être pour
certains membres de l'otan comme c'est
le cas de la norvège pour d'autres avoir
été membre l'association européenne de
libre-échange inventé par les
britanniques en 1960 et que les
différents états en kit et au fur et à
mesure qu'ils adhéraient à l'union
européenne et par conséquent c'est
quelque chose d'assez soupe ce conseil
nordique finalement a aussi un autre
intérêt c'est qu'il sert de noyaux au
conseil de l'arctique
si on y ajoute les grandes les grandes
puissances que sont les états unis et la
russie
plus le canada et bien on a le conseil
nordique avec un certain nombre
d'observateurs dont la france et d'autre
et d'autres pays européen et le conseil
de l'arctique
évidemment devient quelque chose de
stratégique avec totalement le
réchauffement climatique
l'ouverture de nouvelles voies le
nouvelle route du nord et il se trouve
que la russie à son tour devant exercer
la présidence à partir du mois de mai
prochain pour deux années donc tout cela
fait beaucoup de raisons pour que le
ministre des affaires étrangères de la
finlande souhaite un bon interlocuteur
pour monsieur sergueï lavrov et la
finlande
comment est-ce qu'elle gère ces
questions de sécurité alors la finlande
qui avait déclaré sa neutralité à
l'époque de l'union soviétique
tiens beaucoup à ce qu'elle appelle
aujourd'hui un alignement militaire par
conséquent elle n'adhère pas et elle n'a
aucune volonté d'adhérer à l'otan
et je crois que la population la
population chinoise est très attaché à
cette forme
réalité ça ne veut pas dire pour autant
qu'elle n'est pas inquiète pour sa
sécurité
il ya d'ailleurs un service militaire
obligatoire une conscription avec une
option pour ceux qui préfèrent le faire
sur une forte sous une forme civile
garçons et filles et par ailleurs
évidemment la finlande qui n'a que six
millions d'habitants a un budget
militaire assez conséquents qui dépasse
maintenant 2% de son pnb il a été
augmenté d'à peu près 50% l'année
dernière elle possède des avions de
chasse une soixantaine d'avions de
chasse multi fonction d'origine
américaine est bien entendu elle a
développé une coopération importante
avec le temps comme d'ailleurs sa
voisine la semaine donc le sujet de la
de la sécurité en finlande est un sujet
important mais la finlande compte
finalement probablement plus sur le
dialogue avec ses voisins que sur son
armement pour assurer la paix et la
sécurité dans la région
merci que le mange maison pour toutes
ces analyses ce décryptage très précis
je rappelle que vous êtes un expert en
relations internationales